كراولي ومحاوله فهم
واشنطن حتى قبل ان تقوم بدراسه مسافه
تلتقطه من بقايا من هذا المنطاد سارعت
للجزم بان هذا المنطاد للتجسس ما تفسير
ذلك برايك
في الحقيقه قالت
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه انه منطاد
للمراقبه
ويجب ان نفهم لاحقا ما اذا كان العمل فيه
يرتبط بالاحوال الجويه وبالمناخ او بعمليه
تجسس وبالنسبه الى الاحداث السابقه طبعا
اذا ما كنا نقارن ما يحصل الان بالسابق
المثير للاهتمام هو قدره هذا الغرض ان
يحلق في الاجواء فوق الاراضي الامريكيه
والبنتاجون سوف يحدد الغرض من هذا المنطاد
باشارته للمنطقه ونقرا هذا الخبر العاجل
نقلا عن وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه بالقول
بان طائره مقاتله تمكنت من اسقاط المنطاد
الصيني قباله ساحل ولايه كارولينا الجنوبي
وهنا اسال ضيفي من بيجيم السيد فيكتور جاو
ايضا كيف تتابع الصين جمله هذه
التطورات بدايه بالاعلام بان هذا المنطاد
انما هو للتجسس وما استتبعه من اجراءات من
قبل واشنطن
اعتقد انه عندما
ظهر الخبر وانتشر كانت الصين تراكماتيه
وصرحت بوضوح نعم هذا منتظم صيني فقدنا
التحكم به الصين غير قاده قادره على
التحكم به ولسوء الحظ وصل الى الاجواء
الامريكيه عبرت الصين عن اسفها ازاء هذا
التطور الذي حصل ودعت الصين الى التعاون
من خلال القنوات القائمه مع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
للانتهاء من هذا الحادث وطبعا يجب ان لا
يؤثر هذا الحادث المؤسف على العلاقات بين
البلدين والوزير بلينكل يجب ان يستمر في
زيارته المقرره الى بيجين لكي
حدث مع نظيره ومع القاده في الصين اذا كي
يتحدث البلدان عن السلام وليس الحرب يجب
ان لا يؤثر علاقات كما قلت سيد فيكتور حتى
ولو تاكد للجانب الامريكي بعد اختبار
بقايا هذا المنطاد بانه كان لاغراض تجسس
ان الحكومه الصينيه اوضحت اننا نتحدث عن
منصادا يهدف الى اجراء دراسات علميه
مرتبطه بالمناخ وانماطي الاحوال الجويه
الى اخره نحن نتحدث عن تصريح واضحا من قبل
الصين لو كانت الصين تود ان تجري عمليه
تجسس لديها اقمار اصطناعيه اكثر تطورا
واكثر تقدما ويمكنني ان اؤكد لكم ان كل
الاراضي في كل البلدان تغطيها الاقمار
الاصطناعيه ما من اسرار في عالمنا اليوم